[Musique]
découvrir les salines de la pointe au
sel ou encore la biodiversité des
plantes du jardin botanique durant les
vacances scolaires les équipements
culturels du département propose
diverses activités pour petits et grands
à mascarin maya et ses parents sont
venus participer à un jeu de piste afin
de retrouver les cinq éléments
indispensables aux plantes
ce jeu de piste va se dérouler sur trois
quarts d'heure grand maximum une heure
il va permettre aux participants de
découvrir ludiquement le jardin avec des
espèces très différentes et les rolls
des éléments qui leur sont à chaque fois
associés aujourd'hui suis venu à fait
découvrir un petit peu les jardins
botaniques plusieurs choses et faire des
activités pendant les vacances
et puis aussi bas voire la biodiversité
de certaines potes que je connais pas et
voilà bah déjà c'est bien de faire ces
choses-là de mettre en fait les plantes
en terre extra
au lieu de jouer à la maison à la
console toute la journée
c'est mieux de je pense aller découvrir
d'autres pilotes qu'on connaît pas trop
l'occasion de passer du temps en famille
de s'amuser tout en apprenant j'ai
trouvé que c'était très important pour
elle de connaître l'ensemble de la
botanique de la réunion et ailleurs afin
qu'elles puissent avoir ce souvenir et
puis préserver plus tard ce genre de de
flore et de faune et de flore c'est une
transmission transmission puis c'est des
moments de partage est la pointe au sel
un groupe d'adolescents a pu être
initiés à la bande dessinée grâce à
fabrice pour bateaux dessinateur
actuellement en résidence d'artiste au
musée du sert et alors c'est à l'atelier
d'initiation à la bande dessinée donc je
reçois un groupe de jeunes gérants jeune
fille et ils sont en train de faire une
oeuvre collective
donc on a une grande banque en bandes de
papier c'est une bande dessinée ont la
gueule de bois de céné géante
quand on conçoit tout chanson une
association de quartier qui permet aux
jeunes de participer à de nombreuses
activités durant leurs vacances avec un
budget de 100 euros par enfant pour
quinze jours ces visites gratuites dans
les équipements du département sont les
bienvenus on ira aussi aux archives
départementales parce que des ados vont
faire un travail sur l'arbre génère de
shit l'europe généalogique
c'est intéressant pour nous pas ça les
dernières comment s'appelle péripéties
qu'on va dire de la vie et face aux
copies de tout ça est bon de ramener les
jeunes un peu vert ce qui reste
notamment le patrimoine que soient
culturelles historiques géographiques
entre autres les jeunes ont pu aussi
découvrir le musée c'est tradition de
fabrication du sel
cette visite constitue en fait à faire
découvrir la pointe au sel qui est un
espace naturel
cible et en même temps faire découvrir
aussi aux jeunes le musée du sel le mist
oric du musée du sel est ce que
renferment vraiment le musée du sel
c'est à dire la tradition la façon de
faire de scène avec les conditions de
fabrication du sel à la pointe au sel
qu'on est ici et dans votre angle de
vacances et ben ali ont été invités par
c'est pour visiter et apprécier comment
est-ce que les été développé et il fait
évoquer comment est-ce que c'est l'effet
est bien comment est-ce que le seuil de
naurouze pour retrouver l'agenda des
vacances rendez vous sur le site du
département www.dhltd.com en 9 7 4 point
fr
[Musique]